there is a common belief that true
leaders are born and they are naturally
charismatic influential people destined
to make a mark while we acknowledge that
this fact might hold true for some
people we also strongly believe that
with dedicated efforts it is absolutely
possible to cultivate the traits and
talents required to become a leader so
whether you were born with the
authoritative abilities of captain
america or not if you want to be a
leader you have to work hard to develop
the characteristics of the greats today
in this video we will help you
understand what leadership is all about
along with the personality traits one
should possess to become a leader
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
so what do you think leadership is all
about does it have anything to do with
seniority or one's position in a
company's hierarchy if you think yes
then you're on the wrong track of
understanding what leadership is
leadership has nothing to do with titles
management or one's personal agendas
it's also not restricted to personality
traits such as a better vision or
charismatic personality it's more like a
process of social influence which
maximizes the efforts of others towards
the achievement of a common goal
it stems from social influence and
requires human resources to achieve the
intended outcomes
business is a never-ending game
the only way to succeed is to focus on
future growth and how you can get there
and with the help of your human
resources and simply put leadership is
the ability to make that happen moving
ahead let's understand the skills that
you must hone to become a successful
leader
the first skill that you should
emphasize is your ability to listen
listening is an active process and it's
the best way to understand what is
happening in an organization
we frequently find ourselves dwelling on
some other thoughts while having a
conversation as a result we miss out on
critical information or even create a
negative impression at the
communicator's end
so you must enhance your ability to
listen to others
you should develop avenues and channels
for voices to be heard specifically for
those who would not otherwise have the
guts to speak up
you don't always come across solutions
to all problems therefore you must
brainstorm and listen to your team to
bring something unique with each
conversation
next up on our list is clear
communication
communication and trust go hand in hand
no matter how great your ideology and
visions are they will go in vain if you
cannot communicate them to your team
correctly with a proper amount of trust
and confidence
that is why transparency is considered
the foundation of effective
communication
a leader should always be open and
honest about what is known and unknown
he should also ensure that every
listener feels the depth of his vision
with the same level of confidence the
third skill is modeling positive
behavior
when you do what you say you generate
trust and credibility among the people
around you
they will instantly start following and
emulating your actions you can think of
this as an element of leading by example
the ability of a leader to inspire
others through his course of action is
known as role modeling
a leader should also always assist his
followers in staying on the path of
growth
to do this we strongly advise that you
keep track of your team's performance
you should appreciate those who are
doing a good job in order to help them
strive for better performance
on the other hand those that are
underperforming should be steered in the
right direction
next up is resilience and selflessness
resiliency is an important skill in
today's fast-paced and extremely
competitive business world
this personality trait is defined as an
ability to get up faster to bounce back
and reshape after going through a
significant loss or failure being a
leader you should be able to remain
confident and poised in difficult
situations
allow yourself some leeway in dealing
with disappointments
this will help you deal with your
failures fast and learn what else you
could have done better
selflessness is also a critical
leadership personality trait
a leader never elevates himself above
his team
if something does not go right the
leader will always take full
responsibility for it
in contrast if success shows up he will
throw away the credits to his teammates
on that note can you all mention one of
your skills that you think can make you
an effective leader
make sure to drop your answer in the
comments section below let's see how
many of us have what it takes to become
a great leader the last on our list is
effective decision making
leaders in general are those who
question the status quo they are
incredible visionaries change savvy and
agile
every decision they make is not
rudimental and risk-free
they take risks knowing that they'll
need to hold themselves accountable if
things don't work out
that's why to become an effective leader
we advise you to develop the skill of
quantitative decision making
thanks to technology we can now use data
to predict future opportunities and make
sound data-driven decisions that can
take a business to new levels of success
being a leader you should be sincerely
enthusiastic and passionate about your
decisions and actions to fulfill them
this will encourage your team to work
hard towards a common goal with the same
level of dedication and enthusiasm
that's all we have for today i hope this
video is helpful to all of you out there
and i wish you all the very best thank
you for watching the video and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here